multiplayer combat on that note here's
matt with more on the modes and missions
ahead
we've talked a little bit about where
you'll play but let's talk about what
you'll play when you get there
in black ops cold war our classic game
modes are returning and they're better
than ever
from the tried and true team deathmatch
domination
and search and destroy to the return of
the competitive game mode control
we've taken a fresh eye to all of your
favorites
we're encouraging more meaningful
gameplay with larger capture zones and
domination
we're updating spawn systems and
hardpoint and now we show you where the
next hardpoint will spawn so you can
regroup
rotate and set up for the next flight
across all of our classic modes
we're working hard to make this the most
rewarding and competitive multiplayer
experience
yet and while your go-to modes are
coming back better than ever
let's talk about the innovative new
modes you'll be going to next
with that let me introduce you to my
teammate marquise gladney
who's here to tell you about the brand
new multiplayer experience we call
vip escort vip escort began with a
question
how can we create a game mode inspired
by the kind of real-life
totally true but completely redacted
black ops that first inspired this
franchise
the result is extraction in its purest
form
a new 616 objective based game mode we
call
vip escort
in black ops we normally task you with
fighting but vip escort turns that on
its head with a new mechanic
if you're selected as a vip your number
one job it's to live
in this team based op your team will try
to escort you off the map or eliminate
the other team trying to stop you
as vip you'll skip create a class you're
too important after all
instead you'll deploy with the kitted
out pistol a smoke grenade a spy plane
for team intel
and a whole lot of hope that your team
knows what the hell it's doing
the mission stay alive and escape the
map to do so you'll need to reach one of
two possible x-fil sites which rotate
over the course of the match to keep
teams on their toes
there are stakes here if you die that
ends the round
but team up and you can get your squad
back on their feet quickly
via last stand and revive
each team's choices and tactics create
layers of strategy
and counter play injecting the best of
black ops themes directly into this
competition
will your team pull cold war mind games
and misdirection by splitting up the
squad to draw fire and create
distractions for the vip
or as a full-on assault more their style
will they travel ahead and scout
run protection detail or take a bullet
for you secret service style
my personal keys to victory i stay close
and escort the vip
and defend them at all costs if the vip
doesn't make it out alive
it won't matter if you do this new
deniable operation only scratches the
surface
of what it means to play cold war
multiplayer
up next we want to share another new way
to play that goes above and beyond that
classic 6v6
experience you've come to expect
combined arms is where multiplayer gets
bigger and better bringing together the
best of multiplayer's large-scale
battles
by combining infantry and vehicular
gameplay into a single cohesive combat
experience
in combined arms domination players will
deploy into 12 versus 12 battles
each customized and unique to its own
environment
but these battles aren't just bigger or
more chaotic we've worked hard to ensure
the two levels of boots on the ground
and all out vehicular warfare complement
and enhance one another on each
map tanks snowmobiles wake runners
gunboats and more these vehicles amplify
the action shore
but they also create jaw-dropping
moments right in the middle of the fight
the way i personally play combined arms
depends on my mood
if i'm going for the win it's rally time
and i'm pushing to capture
every objective on the map whether that
means loading up a gunboat on armada
or popping smoke so my team can cross
the frozen lake and crossroads
i'm putting my tryhard pants on and
making it happen
and that's the thing in combined arms
almost anything can happen
i'll seek out fun moments that aren't
possible in other modes
like zip lining onto the enemy's ship
and seeing how long i can last before
getting taken
out at launch you can expect even more
combined arms maps and modes
each tailored and tuned to bring the
most fun frenetic action this format can
deliver
take armada our most unique map to date
you saw earlier that the only life
preservers on this sea based map are
your tactics
as each capture zone requires a
different approach will you attack
surgically with a two-seater wake runner
gather your squad and storm the main
ship from zip lines that traverse the
map to all new naval tactics
our motta is combine arms domination
realized
bringing high stakes high speed combat
to the high seas
on crossroads you'll trade your wetsuit
for a snowsuit
fighting for control of soviet bunkers
across the frozen tundra
with high power tanks patrolling the
frozen lake and surrounding roads
you'll need to choose how to take on
those slow movers
so whether you're hopping onto a
snowmobile for a quick flank
rolling up your sleeves and sticking on
some c4 story is yours to write in
combined arms domination
that's it for deniable operations for
now we zipline crossed
frozen lakes and dipped into miami's
beaches that's really just the start of
the full deniable ops experience
add up the work on your favorite classic
game modes to the arrival of new modes
like vip escort
and combined arms domination and it all
stacks up to our most ambitious
multiplayer yet
one you can play any way you want and in
new ways you never expected if you're a
call of duty league fan
we have a bunch of new stuff lined up
just for you stay tuned
this may be a multiplayer game built for
everyone but these will be your deniable
operations
and now i'll turn it over to tony to
talk about what we mean when we say
signature combat thanks matt